here now with more reaction is senior
counsel president trump kellyanne conway
fox news contributor laura trump laura
let's get your thoughts on that and much
more i'll let you take it from there
well i think mark hit on something
really important the problem is just the
democrat party by and large i mean they
have a big problem on their hands as
they're heading to 2022 because no one
wants to buy what the democrats are
selling what are they running on open
borders inflation empty shelves all
across our country high crime defunding
the police
making us dependent on foreign oil again
i mean they really have given americans
nothing positive he is exactly right
their goal at the end of the day
is to socialize america that's not just
an unpopular
message in this country it is unamerican
people have not flocked to america since
the inception of our country because of
socialism they have flocked here because
of our freedoms because of our
capitalist system that says if you come
to america no matter who you are no
matter where you started and you have
the the will to work hard and you have a
dream there is no limit to what you can
achieve in america and right now they
want to stifle that they don't want
people to have dreams they want to
divide us they want to make sure that we
are fully reliant on the government
going forward from here on out socialism
as mark just pointed out has never
worked anywhere it's ever been tried and
quite frankly if we do not take back the
house the senate in 22 and then the
white house in 24 we are in a huge mess
as a country and i don't know if we can
ever recover but never forget who
brought it to you
a a house a senate and a white house
fully run by democrats ladies and
gentlemen that who that's who has
brought you the total and complete
disaster that we have in america right
now
well said i i can't add to that
kellyanne i'll ask you the question this
way we do know how to solve these
problems if we wanted to solve the
border issue we'd go back to the trump
policies if we wanted to solve the
energy issues we'd go back to the trump
policies
if we care about americans we abandoned
in afghanistan we we go in and rescue
them sooner than later i don't believe
in leaving them behind the economic
damage that is being done in large part
because of energy this can all be
reversed kellyanne but it's not going to
happen with this radical group of
democrats in this party
no and if anything they're trying to
impose their will in us in fact
i know people call them gaffs and mental
acuity lapses but these are just lies
buildback better cost zero dollars
that's false we won't strand anybody in
afghanistan that's a lie
we i mean he lies about his background
on amtrak also
that we the border is secure a lie
there's not a crisis a lie and i think
we have to call them to account out in
the lies this is another thing that's
being reflected in the polls now joe
biden doesn't have a mandate as it is
because he has a 50 50 senate and a very
slim hairline
majority in the house so he doesn't have
a mandate really in washington he
doesn't have a mandate in the polls now
and yet his staff has convinced him he
should be fdr sprinkled with a little
aoc and it's a toxic combination for the
rest of us that's why it's led to infi
inflation nation if you look at the
latest poll shawn three quick things
number one 54 disapprove of joe biden's
handling the economy he has given us
inflation nation number two inflation is
now tied with covid as the major concern
in america think about that for a moment
and that's because the cost of living is
something that people need to grapple
with those same folks who benefited the
blue-collar workers from energy
independence under president trump and
the tax cut and jobs act under president
trump and the deregulation and the small
business boone under president trump
they're now suffering under joe biden's
policies and inflation is tied with
kovan number three it's the pessimism we
see in going forward 46 of the people in
the cnbc poll say the economy will be
worse over the next year that's the
highest number since 2008 when we had an
economic collapse they don't see any
time in sight they wish we had the trump
policies back they know we can do this
and we know we had better days before
and it's only going to get worse
kellyanne thank you laura trump thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else